elle marie josée du préposé aux
bénéficiaires depuis juin 1980 le ch est
cédée armand lavergne à montréal fait
partie du réseau public
la direction nous a ouvert les portes
pour passer deux jours avec des préposés
je fais le tour de mes cartons et de du
rapport de nuit deux femmes qui malgré
tout ce qu'on entend sur les chs elle
dit continue d'aimer et croire en leur
métier chris d'honneur c'est
l'infirmière aujourd'hui donc on a eu
une chute il ya eu à shipshaw résidente
assez tôt ce matin de temps en temps ça
commence comme ça n'est pas eu deux que
j'ai peur que de mal
[Musique]
ça doit être parce que nous trouvons
belles batailles que nous trouve belle
on voyais qt
bonjour moi c'est mélanie et puis je
suis dans le domaine de la santé depuis
bientôt 25 montre la santé que je quand
je parle de mon domaine c'est vraiment
une histoire de coeur c'est pas la tâche
je sens par beaucoup beaucoup de la
tanche on parlait les tâches qu'on a les
fonctions moi c'est possible c'est une
histoire de casse la compassion c'est
d'être là pour les gens qui sont son
venir à vous savez les résidents qui
sont ici c'est les gens les plus
vulnérables de notre société
c'est des gens qui ont besoin de nous
c'est au préposé de ch et celle des
comme mélanie marie-josée des femmes des
hommes que le québec confie ses citoyens
les plus vulnérables les défis que nous
rencontrons avec terry sedan préserver
leur hôtel parce que les raisons qui
rendent ici le background souvent qui a
réussi ce qu'on faisait des déficits
cognitifs des démences une perte
d'autonomie qui est quasi totale thrive
comme vous l'aimez
ils ont souvent besoin de moi pour tout
tout tout tout tout tout ce qu'on pense
tout ce que les gens font le matin qui
vous paraît normal de faire seul qu'on
remarque pas moi je dois le faire pour
eux
je lui ai donné son griot donc je lui ai
dit que c'était sucré c'était ça
céréales
que savons-nous boucher à la foire je
surveille ça paraît pas mais je
surveillais dans le coup de voir
l'action d'avaler ce mur lui redonne pas
une nouvelle bouche et angers pauvreté
ils ont un potentiel qu'il faut penser
que sont capables d'exprimer son
potentiel lot et c'est de tout faire à
leur place c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire à droite
à ces mots mais comme il faut sur votre
ou vos poignets on s'est beaucoup pour
eux mais jamais ce qu'ils sont capables
de faire
par contre ça va bien comme ça se fait
des bonds pas debout c'était disait vous
avez fait un exercice pour vos jambes
bonjour madame diane comment ça va mais
y'a des fois que guère possible professé
sur quelque chose
préposé aux bénéficiaires sont tous bien
conscients de la perception très
négative que la population a de l'avis
ans et chez celles d ici personne ne se
met la tête d'un sable quand on est là
pour assurer le bien-être des gens il ya
toujours place à amélioration
mais concentrer le débat sur des
éléments bien précis comme des deux
mains par semaine ce n'est pas ça qui va
vraiment améliorer le sort des résidents
or l'histoire des bains ces histoires le
rouge en pensez quoi mais moi ça me rend
malheureuse en temps ça parce que c'est
des petits c'est un petit groupe car je
sais que c'est important jamais voyons
c'est oui mais j'ai tellement plus c'est
d'abord et avant tout le choix de la
personne en avoir un ou deux s'avance un
petit peu et moi je trouve que comme je
disais vous mais certains jours vous
verrez pas la différence que la personne
- ben ouais t'es quoi les faits ou
l'arabe buruli préposés aux
bénéficiaires c'est pas juste ça se
maitient pas juste à s'en aller gène
l'alimentation en eau drôle dit de
dialogue de conversations d'intégrer
notre personne de s'intégrer elles sont
quotidiens si mon lieu de travail mais
c'est avant tout leur milieu de vie
j'ai des ambitions et des activités dans
le monde et karaoké qu'est ce que vous
aimez chanter le plus n'importe quoi
[Musique]
j'ai proposé des poissons jusqu'à six
mois juste que les gens soient capables
de m'interpeller par mon nom j'ai trois
résidents qui sont capables de
m'interpeller par mon nom c'est donc y
en a un lien qui s'est faite on va aller
porter un jour monsieur c'est pas facile
parce que oui le métier est difficile et
demandant le métier change on doit
s'adapter
on nous demande plus parce qu'il faut
aussi donner plus parce que notre
population est vieillissante des plus en
plus malade car si si la vie semble
tourner au ralenti
les préposés n'arrête tout simplement
jamais on doit faire ce qu'on doit
toujours entre voient en vous avez jugé
qu est ce qui s'en vient quelle est la
prochaine étape
qu'est ce que notre résident un besoin
qu'est ce qui faciliterait sa vie
aujourd'hui
alors on doit toujours est allé fut
toujours est allumée toujours être en
mouvement
mais en même temps toujours très calme
et toujours à leur rythme mais en ayant
des tâches qui doivent s'accomplir
obligatoirement c'est ici vous voulez
m'emmener un peu ok le besoin le plus
criant ici c'est la main d'oeuvre très
beaux arts
oui avec la population qui vieillit les
cas toujours plus lourd à soigner les
préposés lance un appel à l'aide dans
l'es17 ch et celle des du centre sud de
montréal
on a besoin dès maintenant 200 préposé
supplémentaire est évidemment qu'un
manque de personnel roulement personnel
c'est pas évident site et altruiste doit
aimer ce domaine la cité patiente
s'était flexible c'est est capable de
s'adapter
tu vas aimer la mer l'on puisse est très
actif est ce qu'on a besoin c'est
justement la valorisation du métier là
valorisation du domaine qui vont faire
que ça va attirer des gens qui ont cette
passion leurs moteurs du rebond jours au
sur vincent président qu'on voit dans
l'ic ont besoin le sabric nous un jour
alors que ce qu'on ait besoin de besoins
du monde au coeur du monde qui veut
s'impliquer qui veulent s'engager que
c'est vraiment ce qu'on le rejoindre
monsieur est secondaire
oui
[Musique]